bonsoir on y re doux mais me merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on vient de voir un les prix des
carburants qui augmente de 30% cause de
la suppression partielle les subventions
qui à terme devrait totalement
disparaître
on se demande comment la population
libanaise va pouvoir faire face alors
que le liban est en plein chaos déjà
c'est une c'est une question en effet
très compliqué nous faisons face
non je pense que le reportage à et c'est
assez a été assez fidèle à ce qui se
passe ici nous faisons face à vrai
véritablement un régime criminel qui
tout en vivant les ces derniers ces
derniers mois probablement vu la
pression auxquels il fait face s'acharne
à faire porter aux libanais le prix de
leur mauvaise gestion durant toutes ces
années
donc nous sommes dans une phase à une
situation où il ya des pertes à partager
dans ce pays un régime confessionnel ne
peut pas partager les pertes tout ce
qu'il peut faire c'est partager le
résultat de leurs deux des deux skins
pays à travers le système
donc ils sont dans l'incapacité de gérer
les pertes façon autre que comptable
comme ils le font aujourd'hui
donc ils font payer le prix aux gens
sans son sens sans aucune considération
pain pour le propos pour la catastrophe
qui leur font vivre au quotidien
clairement est ce qu'il y aurait une
autre solution et si oui laquelle
oui il y à une solution je fais partie
d'un parti politique qui militent pour
cette solution depuis 2016 puisque nous
avons été fondés spécifiquement parce
que nous savions que le système arrivé à
sa fin de route
la solution au liban aujourd'hui et
l'établissement
et l'établissement d'un état laïc qui
serait confiant dans sa légitimité qui
serait capable lui même de gérer les
pertes de façon équitable entre les
libanais encore une fois le système
confessionnel pas parce que il ne sait
pas ou parce qu'il ne veut pas mais
parce qu'il ne peut pas fonctionner lmnp
aujourd'hui traités avec une situation
pareille
et effectivement après avoir fait subir
15 ans de guerre aux libanais les chefs
de guerre confessionnelle continuent
leur leur traitement de criminels de la
situation aujourd'hui quinze ans après
la fin plutôt trente ans après la fin de
la guerre enfin à la fin de la guerre
mais plutôt la fin des hostilités parce
que la guerre elle même n'est pas
terminé puisque nous vivons une
situation qui est ok aussi caraquet et
qui est aussi catastrophique donc
aujourd'hui il y a des gens au liban
dont nous faisons partie qui sont en
train de militer pour l'établissement
d'un état véritable dans ce pays seuls
capables de gérer une crise telle que
nous la vivons parce que sinon vous avez
mentionné les interventions enfin une
intervention assez dirait limite comics
de l'ambassadeur américain qui au bien
de mrs étrangères américain qui c'est
qui s'est réuni avec ses homologues
saoudiens et français et qui appelle à
des réformes
la quantité de crise nous aujourd'hui au
liban ne peut être résolue par des
réformes c'est un mot qui est qui et qui
est quasiment qu'il ya une dimension de
d'insultés aux gens ils nous avons un
véritablement besoin d'un changement de
système complet et encore une fois il y
a des gens qui s'y activent et qui
essaye de faire en sorte que cette crise
ne sont pas une fatalité mais une
opportunité pour se diriger vers quelque
chose qui puisse redonner de l'espoir
aux libanais et cette chose-là n'inclut
pas les chefs de guerre confessionnelle
allié des états-unis de la france
d'ailleurs le magazine américain foreign
policy a son idée sur la question il a
consacré quelques colonnes cette crise
libanaise est dit en substance à
l'impasse libanaise est en partie la
faute d' emmanuel macron est ce que vous
partagez cet avis expliquant il faut
lire évidemment cet article complet mais
en gros que la france agit td des
sanctions qui n'ont jamais eu lieu
c'était un échec finalement de
l'initiative française
écoutez nous en tant que mouvement nous
avons suivi de tp l'évolution de la
position française qui a oscillé entre
les premiers jours qui ont suivi
l'explosion du port de beyrouth du 4 2
du 4 août
cette position s'est développée c'était
au début
au début c'était un peu vain puis c'est
devenu un gouvernement de mission puis
ensuite ils se sont pliés au
gouvernement d'union nationale comme
ceux qui ont géré le pays durant les 15
dernières années et qui ont montré leur
incapacité à de faire pour arriver à une
dernière déclaration de jean yves le
drian le ministre des affaires
étrangères qui avait déclaré il y a dix
il y a deux mois à peu près si je ne
m'abuse qu' il était temps de nous avoir
un gouvernement de transition qui puisse
prendre les pays et une direction
différente me semble que ce n'était que
des déclarations à ce moment là la
france aujourd'hui ce
montre encore une fois son incapacité à
dépasser son attachement à un système
qu'elle a finalement contribué à
instaurer
il y a longtemps de cela et encore une
fois et les face à l'impasse et donc ce
n'est pas seulement le rôle de la france
mais de tous les pays qui ont un intérêt
dans la région je parle de la france des
états unis de la russie de l'iran
tous ces pays là n'ont pas intérêt à ce
que le liban tombe dans le chaos parce
que vous ça aurait un impact très
néfaste sur eux et donc la seule
solution pour eux et l'établissement
d'un état
il ne s'agit pas d'appeler à une
intervention étrangère mais de mes deux
déclaré très clairement qu'aujourd'hui
c'est ce dont le pays a besoin et de
commencer et éventuellement à le
déclarer à le déclarer très clairement
de façon maintenant vous coupez mais
vous dites voilà votre parti souhaite à
un état laïc
aujourd'hui que l'avant est ce que les
conditions sont réunies pour la création
de cet état laïc ça semble si compliqué
écoutez le problème c'est que c'est le
seul régime qui est une légitimité
capable de gérer la crise ce n'est pas
parce que nous parce que la situation
s'y prête ou pas ou parce que certains
ont envie ou pas malheureusement le
régime actuel je pense que c'est devenu
clair votre reportage a été très très
clair à ce niveau là est incapable de
gérer la crise et il c'est une crise de
régime ce n'est pas une crise économique
ce n'est même pas une crise qui est
simplement politique
d'accord c'est qu'une crise
fondamentalement de régime est donc le
seul régime qui soit capable de gérer la
crise soit la seule la seule entité
institutionnels qui sont capables de
gérer une crise pareille est un état et
dans l'état des choses au liban cet état
ne peut avoir qu'une légitimité naik
s'il veut avoir la chance de se
maintenir et de véritablement distribuer
les pertes de façon équitable et avec un
objectif parce que aujourd'hui
c'est ce que les libanais à temps merci
m mounir domani membres du parti
libanais citoyens et citoyennes dans un
état d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france